hi and welcome back to episode 115 of
let's play roller coaster in three I am
not letting go of this game yet
definitely not though I might actually
in the future ones planet coaster and
roller coaster current world might seem
like some good games but that's really
something to talk about later on I and
yes I am buying both of them but really
the reason why this video is so
tremendously late and I haven't uploaded
anything in a week is because I went to
Austria last week and I figured I would
at least record a video and keep that
uploaded and make it public while I am
in Austria but that didn't happen or at
least it it sort of did happen but only
for a little while because when I
uploaded it at home I forgot to actually
make it private and or planned and that
is and I accidentally made it public and
made it private again after one second
but then when I made it public and
Austria halfway through the week to at
least
release a video at Christmas is for some
reason it didn't send into people's
subscriber feeds and I couldn't even
find it on my channels home page so I
have no idea what I would have actually
done in that case and figured oh well
whenever only 60 people actually found
the video which I am sorry about
removing it again but here it is
I've actually recorded this video again
to add some new commentary because the
old one had some terribly rushed one
that I recorded just in time before my
vacation so in the end this should
probably for the better and be for the
better and I'm also back and I've got
one more week of vacation so I'll
probably be making loads and loads of
videos so at least I should hopefully
have more uploads this upcoming period
and now about the game itself really I
think this yeah this is the final
episode where I kind of finished these
facades because it was about goddamn
time that I finished these facades it's
been taking a very long time I might
still add some extra details I am I
haven't really finished the the lower
size of these facades as much as I would
like to and they they still seem very
gray brownish and really without color
though I have to be quite honest I don't
know if I wanna
like that or not because for one part of
it I I feel really on the fence about
it's about having such a very gray ish
college around this area since it
doesn't look too appealing and I'd
rather have more bright College but then
again this is England and it's
stereotypically England to have grey
everywhere and be very gloomy and such
so yeah I might I might just add more
foliage and change a couple of colour
schemes a little bit but this this
should probably be the overall
atmosphere that I do want to go for for
this area not to mention that it will
probably fit the dark ride quite a lot
since basically what I do want to go for
with the dark ride is available on an
underground theme I do want to at least
theme it around a story and not just a
random dark ride that is there to look
good and be a fun experience but I want
to get some sort of English folklore to
theme it around which I have no idea if
it will actually be good and I really
truly hope that it will be good somehow
because this is actually the first time
that if I do finish it I ever finish a
dark ride it's something that I have
barely any experience with which is
really against what I stand for
I usually at least want to do things
which I do have experience with and know
that I can pull them off which is
definitely not the case for a dark ride
but hopefully I'll be able to pull
through with some sort of I don't know
some sort of odd legend like Jack the
Ripper check you and hide things stuff
like that would be pretty cool I'm gonna
check out and rewatch hath earth hath
videos or rather I should comb HS
designs today because he actually has a
couple of amazing tutorials on dark
rides and if you're ever looking to make
some dark rides you don't really have
too good of an idea where to start i
really suggest you check out HS designs
tutorials because his dog rides are
really good but he has some videos where
he kind of shares his thoughts and the
way in which he works which is really a
big eye-opener and probably without it i
won't even be able to start making a
dark ride
and at least I have some sort of basic
idea and planning behind what I want to
do with it so it should in the end be
pretty good and also pretty fun I'm sort
of looking forward to trying it though
that said I am really really gonna have
to try it on an empty sandbox I've
actually gotten more crushes recently
you might see it in the videos sometimes
it I don't know if it is in this video
yet or more in episode 116 but sometimes
video just skips a certain part and
teleports from one part of the park to
another I just have some crushes every
now and then and it's quite quite
annoying I'm gonna have to use basic
save a lot more than I did as well which
also for the you know slows down my
progress but it's just it's pretty damn
painful and I can't really make it no I
cried on this park map I want to keep it
as empty as possible and a dark ride
with all the effects and very small
detailed scenery on it is definitely not
gonna really help this park to actually
function so I'm gonna just have to
remove it really in the end the thing
that I wanted to do in this little
square was to have one of these sort of
eating areas outside which is something
which I don't really do too often and
should probably do much more often and I
would even say that might comment for
many more people out there what some
theme parks have here and there is
they'll have an area where you just have
some restaurants very small little shops
and stalls here and there and in the
middle you've got one very big path or
area or some some kind of square and in
the middle of that you have these tables
which aren't really connected to a
specific restaurant or anything you can
just kind of sit down there and have a
little a cup of tea or a crumpet and
that's sort of the thing that I wanted
to have here in the middle so on one
side I kind of wanted to have this
planter over here which looks like a
bird from that one perspective you can
kind of see it for like split seconds
every now and then but I think it's
already sort of lost its its bird looks
and this is where I wanted to have some
simple foliage around it and of course
some nice benches that people could sit
on
just kind of chill with their family or
something like that and then underneath
the pavilion because this is England
it's gonna rain 24/7 so I need some sort
of roof over the eating area I'm gonna
have some picnic tables no actually not
picnic tables just a normal sort of
garden tables that people can sit on and
have a nice little a nice little bagel
or coffee and so that's pretty much why
I figured I would do with this area and
it should also help make this area look
just a little bit less gray and brownish
because it is almost depressing how gray
and brownish it looks that's definitely
something that I wanted to get rid of
and make this area at least a bit more
bright and uplifting because you know in
the end I don't want to go for complete
realism no just that is not just an
excuse that I want to get out there
because I can't make completely
realistic buildings not because I well
yeah I can't make completely realistic
buildings because partly I don't know
that much about specific themes just
really know that bare bones of how it
should make it look like something but
not entirely be something and there just
isn't enough for some scenery out there
to make 100 percent recreations of
certain themes and styles but I don't
think it's a bad thing really something
that you should always keep in mind is
that this is a theme park after all and
real theme parks have some leeway and
what they weren't though themes to look
like as well it never really looks like
the exact themes that you'd find in real
life I was actually as especially
disappointed looking at the Dutch area
in Europa Park and barely really
recognizing the country that I live in
sometimes the bikes just have a bit of
that freedom to make things look
whatever they want to or whatever they
can make things look like and it's in a
theme park never really realistic one of
the things which I don't know who it was
I saw actually very sorry if you were
the person who said it to me I can't
remember anymore but somebody made a
comment saying what's kind of funny in
the roller-coaster second three
community is how they
are all these realistic rock sets and
everybody mixes them to create such
beautiful rock facades and mixes them
with foliage in beautiful ways and
created such such detailed Rocky
Mountains whereas in real life with
theme parks is do is they get random
concrete pour it down somewhere and
paint over it if they're very luxurious
but sometimes they just pour down random
concrete's and then call it a day there
and say yeah this is a this is a rock
now this is a beautiful mountain which
is very much like to the contrary of
that the roller coaster in three parts
usually have much more realistic rocks
which are can I find kind of funny as
almost more realism in some relative
second three parks then there is in real
life sometimes which is weird how that
can work out but yeah the basic message
of that random story that went all over
the place is that you don't always have
to completely stress your realism
sometimes you just have to go for your
fantasy as well or if you can't really
get that perfect level of realism don't
have to worry about it because real life
pikes don't do it as well it might be
just a bit more realistic to make your
things look not so realistic as much of
a paradox as that is in any case I'm
running out of time for this episode so
thank you guys for watching and I'll see
you guys in the next episode